yeah you know I came in this morning
with a new accessory I don't know if you
can see it it walked in everyone's
giving me high-fives everyone's real
impressed but Bret was kind of not
feeling it for some reason or another
and I know he is kind of known as the
guy with the beard now that I'm the guy
with the mustache and I'm kind of better
than the guy with the beard
Bret's taking it pretty hard Ben shaved
his face into a mustache doing this
every every every since he's got this
mustache he's been just a real jerk you
know is that where he's like he becomes
now like a mouth breather like this has
become more important he has he's little
comments that he hey Ben are you doing
thought I heard something over here all
right
go Movember you know if I could tell
Brett anything I'd say you know maybe
get a mustache but don't cuz I have won
the mustaches and the goatees are pretty
much taking I tell Brett you know stay
in your lane keep your beard do a
mustache but don't do it around me just
live your life man I'll live mine
spinmaster hooked us up with these
awesome Air Hogs drones these are racing
drones for beginners now since we're all
super advanced fliers we'd figured we'd
skip straight to the fun part and fly
them around the studio while we try to
shoot him down with guns he's how this
is going to work the racer is gonna
start down in the end of the hallway
below the stairs gonna run the drone
through the hallway around the corner
into the studio down this video into the
kitchen back around the studio and land
it on the judge's table
well most of the runway will be people
with guns and they may fire at will the
drone comes into range wait how far that
way does the don't have to go it's go
all the way up to the kitchen okay
if he can fly it up off the ground
without picking it up and you can
continue flying I'm really looking
forward to seeing grants performance
today I think he's been doing a lot of
practice he's been really excited about
this cambro six three two one
[Music]
[Music]
like obviously if you can shoot it
point-blank wallets I'm trying to slow
down and land where obviously you're not
gonna be able to land ready here we go
Niko how are you gonna do this better
than Sam what are your secrets and
technical faster it's either I'm gonna
do some tricks why fly
[Music]
No
finish me off
you know Nikko flew admirably except for
the crash I'd say he was in it to win it
but you know the thing is is that Sam
just got further than he did and you
know that counts for something
Sam was also doing a couple cool mom
tricks paris' approaching the light and
then backing on yeah
Gretchen white dude moth Trix are dude
drone math tricks birthday that's it
next lesson new thing right now
now it's Ren's turn hopefully Ren will
put out this dumpster fire
[Music]
[Applause]
oh stop only hear the Rost emotion the
true is feeling the most real butthurt
the Hilux race drone from Air Hogs I
have no prior drone experience I've
never flown a racing drone but they say
that these drones are for beginners well
I'm about to test that theory first
light
[Music]
how's it handling I don't know go home
only used one lever the nice thing is
it's got these bumpers on it so you
don't worry about breaking it
[Music]
know where to go
she's down yeah we gotta go get it did
you see where it went down yeah we're
not supposed to be up here so we gotta
get out of here feel like I learned
something about droning I learned that
it's not all your left stick or your
right stick sometimes it's both
think about that hey Carl
can I talk to you for a minute
how's it going man all right the reason
why I brought you back here honestly is
because there's been way too many
spelling errors on the salmon equal
channel lately and yeah um no no hold on
don't talk just hear me out I just I
can't have it you know the channels
growing there's more more videos now I
think you need to take some time off and
I don't know go back to where you came
from and learn the English language come
back when you're ready
you know don't put a timeframe on it but
I'm from Germany oh well they're great
in English you should have no problem
then yeah are you firing me uh no I
think it's more like deportation if we
had to put a term on it you know I don't
want to put a term on it so anyways
perfect time to go the holidays are
coming around the corner we've got this
corridor shirt you can get yourself one
of these it's cold in Germany I heard so
get one of these sweatshirts corridor 15
on Crabbe made.com backslash corridor
digital will get you one of these bad
boys oh and don't forget to upload that
last video before you leave cool all
right good talk catch you later
don't forget 4:15 Gordon digital comm
backslash store
Oh
this is mayor